Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Yes, I am still echoing because I am still traveling.
I'm still not back at home yet.
Soon, though.
Soon, soon.
But today, we are gonna be playing Deltarune.
Yes!
Okay, I know some people are far-sounding.
Wait, do I sound like I'm really far away?
Should I up my mic a little bit more?
Okay, oh my gosh.
I wish I had, like, a thing where I can raise this up a little, but I forgot to get, like, a thing, a perch.
Wait, I think I can use this.
Okay.
Okay, give me a sec.
I think I can use this.
I think I can use this as, like, a little perch thing.
Alright.
It's like, it's my wallet.
I'm using, but, okay.
Okay.
Okay, I might sound a little closer now.
Do I sound... Wait.
Oh, my God.
I have a blanket on my fucking legs because... Because it's cold.
Does it sound better?
Guys, I am a little closer.
This is... Does it sound a little... A lot better now?
Okay.
A bit?
I could.
Um... Is it a little better now?
Uh... Yes, my wallet has...
Mine's a zipper.
Mine's a zip wallet.
Um... It's, like, those really long wallets.
Uh... It's, like, those really long wallets.
The rectangular ones.
And you zip it open and you zip it... Yeah.
Anyway.
Okay.
So, um...
What was I gonna say?
Oh, yeah.
Uh... Deltarune.
Um... I won't lie and say that...
This is not my first time playing Deltarune.
Um... But, uh... I only played Chapter 1.
So, uh...
Chapter 1.
And that was 7 years ago.
That was 7 years ago.
If you guys don't remember...
Deltarune, Chapter 1, released on Halloween in 2018.
And that was the first time and last time I've ever played Deltarune.
Because I knew, I knew, fucking Toby Fox would take years.
Because when I saw that he was like, I'm releasing it chapter by chapter.
And not making, like, not fully releasing a completed game.
I knew he would take fucking forever to finish this game.
So, I was like, I'm gonna wait.
I was like, I'm gonna wait until the game is more finished.
Because I have a feeling he was gonna take a long time to finish the entire game.
Um, because if he's gonna make it episodic, I am not fucking waiting.
Like, it's a Netflix show where the Stranger Things has also taken seven plus years...
By the way, if you guys wanna know, Stranger Things has also followed the exact time frame.
Where I believe it's been running for, like, seven plus years now.
And...
And I don't fucking know what goes on in between seasons anymore.
I don't know.
Because it takes so long for each new season.
It takes so long.
It takes, like, I don't know, like, two plus years to film one season.
That, like, that, like, I have to wait two plus years for each season.
That I just forget what happens the last season.
So, I... that's why I waited.
I waited until the game is getting more completed.
Before...
Before we go on to...
Oh, yeah.
Season one for Stranger Things was nine years ago.
That's even...
That makes it so much worse.
Holy fuck.
Okay.
Yeah.
It was nine years ago.
So, I wasn't...
Or, like, you know...
Or, like, an Amazon series.
Seriously.
It's, like...
I'm...
I'm so tired.
Okay.
I've wanted to rant about this for the longest time.
And this is, like, the perfect time to rant about it.
But I am so fucking tired of shows taking fucking years in between filming for the next season.
Like, I understand.
Like, it takes a long time to film these shows.
Because, you know, they want to have good quality.
But I don't know what's going on anymore.
I don't know.
Because, like...
Because it takes so long to release in between seasons.
And then I have to watch a recap episode to remember what happens last season or maybe three seasons ago.
Like, I forgot what's going on.
Like, I remember trying to watch...
Oh, my God.
What was it?
The Boys.
Oh, my God.
When, like, The Boys new season came out.
I remember, like...
Like, every time The Boys new season comes out, I'm like, what the fuck happened?
I don't remember.
I was like...
I didn't have to watch the recap episode.
Because I'm like, what the fuck happened?
Like...
What happened?
I don't know.
I was like, wait, who's this guy again?
And, like, oh yeah, this happened.
Oh yeah, we're trying to figure out this thing.
Same with, like, any Netflix show.
Any fucking Netflix show that comes out and, like, you're, like, invested in it.
But then you're, like, you unfortunately got invested in it in season one.
So... So you're, like, what the fuck happened?
Like... That happened to me on BoJack Horseman.
When BoJack Horseman was still playing...
And then, like, you know, it took, like, years for, like, you know, because it's an animated show.
It takes years for it to release in between.
And I always forget.
I have to... I always forget.
I was, like, what the fuck did BoJack do again?
Like, how did he fuck up again?
I don't remember.
I... He fucks up so many times.
And it's been so fucking long.
I watched three other TV shows already.
I am not remembering these plot points.
I... It's been way too long.
So... So... So... Anyway.
So this is the same as Deltarune.
So, like I said, I played Deltarune Chapter 1.
Um... Back in 2018.
And I waited.
I... And now I heard that Toby Fox has released two new chapters.
But it's still not complete yet.
So I guess... Maybe I should have waited.
I don't know.
Eight more years before I started my Deltarune playthrough.
But I needed... I needed... I was just like... Ah, fuck it.
Like, I don't know what to stream this week.
And I need something that doesn't take up, like, 60 gigabytes of RAM.
And, like... I was like, you know what?
Like, Deltarune just... Like, the two new chapters of Deltarune just came out...
Came out, like, two days ago.
Or yesterday.
Yesterday.
It gets the right... I guess it gets the right time to start.
All right.
I'm gonna forget all four chapters when Chapter 5 fucking comes out in eight years.
But, like...
Like, what can I do?
Like...
It's too late.
Maybe... Maybe by the time I finish Chapter 4, Chapter 5 will come out.
I'll...
Oh, yeah!
Chapter 5 in 2020... Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I forgot.
Spoiler alert.
They confirmed Chapter... They... I remember Toby Fox tweeted out today.
Sorry.
Toby Fox tweeted out today.
Um... That, like... Oh, yeah.
You finished all four chapters.
Remember to, like, not quit right away.
Because he told... Said that Chapter 5 is coming out in...
2026.
But, sorry.
Let me correct myself.
I meant... Maybe by then, the game will be completed in six years.
Sorry.
Let me make a little correction.
I meant the game being completed.
Like...
I feel like, at that point, maybe...
Hope's crushed.
Yeah.
Um... Also...
Sound guy, if there's any edits I need to do for my sound...
Uh... When we boot up the game...
You can chat on... In chat.
Because I finally fixed YTC filter.
Um...
But, yeah.
We're gonna see how far we can do for Chapter 1.
Um... I don't know if I can finish Chapter 1.
Um... All the way today.
Like I said, I don't remember much about Chapter 1.
Except for the plot twist.
I know the ending...
Of...
I knew... I know the ending of Chapter 1.
So, like, I won't be surprised by that.
Because that was, like...
I felt like the...
I remember...
The ending of Chapter 1 was, like, you know...
The whole...
The biggest plot twist.
Like...
Like, it was, like, the...
Gotcha moment for Chapter 1.
So, I do remember Chapter 1.
Despite it being...
Seven years.
So...
Um...
Yeah.
It was, like, the...
The cliffhanger.
So...
Uh...
So, I still remember how it ends.
Um...
But other than that...
Uh...
That's, like, all I could remember.
Like...
I...
I don't remember anything.
Anyway...
Some people were asking about my history with Undertale.
Um...
I have not...
Oh, someone was like...
Oh, we noticed that your thing...
Um...
The thing...
Uh...
It says, until next heist.
I do have a new schedule template.
Hehe.
But I'm waiting until later to use it.
I don't want to, like, drop it right off the bat.
But, like, I do have a new schedule template.
And I have, like, new stuff.
But, like...
Not today.
Not when I'm on vacation.
Quote, unquote.
Technically, when I'm not working, it's considered a vacation.
Honestly, streaming is a vacation from the actual work I had to do.
I was literally, uh...
For the concert...
Um...
I was, like, doing so much stuff.
But, like...
Streaming is my vacation right now from my actual work stuff.
Because, um...
Right before I started my stream...
I was in...
I was talking with, like, five different people...
For behind-the-scenes work.
Like, I was just, like, on Discord.
Like, ba-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la.
With five different people.
Like...
And then I'm like...
Yay!
Vacation break time!
It's time to play Deltarune!
That's my vacation!
Like...
The best of both worlds...
Ba-da-ba-da-da-da.
Da-da-ba-da-ba-ba.
Sorry.
Oh my god.
I should have put Hannah Montana on my set list.
Hannah Montana is not on my set list, guys.
Oh my god.
I should have put that.
Best of both worlds.
Anyway,
okay, sorry.
Undertale.
So my history of Undertale.
I've never played Undertale by myself before.
I've watched every known playthrough...
Okay, not known, I don't even watch every playthrough.
But I've watched, like, a lot of playthroughs of majority of the routes for... or, yeah, for all the routes for Undertale.
So, you know, I've done...I watched the Genocide route.
I watched the, uh, you know, the Peaceful route.
I watched the, you know, the , and I watched every ending and every route you could do for Undertale because I was obsessed with Undertale, but I wasn't, like, one of those people that played the games.
Because, uh...
Before I streamed...
before I was streamer, Absolutely.
I never liked playing single-player games.
I like watching other people play single-player games.
And I would just play multiplayer games.
I don't know, for me, for some reason, I just don't like playing single-player games by myself.
I don't know.
That's why now I'm catching up on all these games that I never got to play before.
Now, I've got to actually play, but I've watched people play.
Um, and getting to experience it myself.
Because I like, you know, playing these games and having you guys there watching me.
Like, I have, like, I don't know, it just feels different.
Having an audience, and I guess having backseaters is just better.
Like... I'm one of those rare VTubers, or not just VTubers, rare streamers that actually enjoy getting backseated.
Because I don't have to think for myself.
Like...
I'm actually, I actually like having that experience.
Um, being, being told what to do.
Like...
Um... Um, so I'm one of, I'm one of the few streamers that I'm, like, okay with backseating.
Uh...
Because, it's like, you know, the streamer buff.
Yeah.
It's so onless and shameless.
Uh, all the concert guests are confirmed.
Yes.
Um, Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not so Deadpool, thank you for the five gifted ships.
Yes, I love to, I love to use the streamer meta.
It's just more fun.
The shared experience is just a lot more fun.
Um, the only game, the, I think, like, one of the few games I've actually played myself.
Like, with, like, you know, like, as a single player is, uh, uh, um, is Stick of Truth from South Park.
Because that game was fucking fun.
Um, that was my game of the year when it came out.
But, South Park Stick of Truth was the, I think was one of the few games I've actually, it was South Park Stick of Truth and StarCraft, um, the campaigns.
That were one of the few games that, like, single player games that actually, like, played by myself, like, without watching other streams.
I didn't watch any streams of that.
I didn't watch any playthroughs.
I actually fully completed the game myself, just playing it.
Um, I think, I don't remember if there's any other games, but those were the two games, uh, that stuck out to me the most.
Someone was asking, I won't, I don't think I'll stream Stick of Truth ever, uh, ever on my channel, because, like, I already played it, so, like, I've explored everything of...
I got, like, a hundred percent completion on Stick of Truth, because I was fucking obsessed with that game.
So, like, it won't be, like, new to me.
Um, and, um, someone was asking me if I should, uh, if I would ever stream Fractured But Whole.
The thing is, I talked to one of my friends about that game, saying I never actually played it.
I haven't played a sequel of it yet.
And then one of my friends told me there is a really, really, really fucked up joke in there.
And it's... that's worse than any of the jokes that are in Stick of Truth.
I don't know what it is.
I mean...
Because I was like, no way, worse than the one about...
I don't know if I can say it.
I was gonna be like, wait, it's worse than, you know, that scene on, you know, you know, about a baby?
I was like, no way, it's worse than... it's worse than that scene about a particular baby?
And then my friend was like, yes, there are... there is a joke where it's worse than that.
And I was like, holy fuck.
Okay.
So, um...
So, I don't... I heard they, like, went... they, like, actually went beyond what Stick of Truth did.
So, I was like, oh, man, I don't know if I can stream that.
I don't know.
Like, everyone's mentioning a different joke.
Okay, but there was one scene in Fractured But Whole that I laughed at.
Because I saw, like, someone on Twitter talking about it and being like, oh my god, this is the...
Like, they say they skipped the cutscene or whatever.
And it was something regarding, like, Diabetes Kid.
Where he was like, with the power of insulin or whatever.
And then, like, they skipped the cutscene.
And then he was just dead.
Like...
So...
So, like...
Okay, Captain Diabetes.
Yeah, so, like, I saw that part.
I thought that was fucking hilarious.
I was like, what the fuck happened?
Like, yes.
I don't know if anybody ever saw that clip.
But that was a really good clip from that... from that game.
Um...
That that how...
Okay, I...
I don't know!
I don't know what joke it is!
My friend just warned me and saying there's a joke worse than...
The thing about the baby in Stick of Truth.
But I can't elaborate more about the baby because it was a pretty bad scene about the baby.
It was...
It was a really bad scene.
Um...
Anyway...
Because that...
I...
I was like, okay, if I stream Stick of Truth, what do I have to worry about?
There is a...
The scene about the balls.
Okay, for those who have ever played Stick of Truth, there's a scene about the balls.
And then there's the...
Any of the scenes that got censored in the Australian version.
For those who don't know...
Um...
The Stick of Truth in Australia got heavily censored.
And they would put like koalas or something over...
They would be like, sorry, because you bought this game in Australia.
We have...
They have censorship rules.
So we're here...
Here you go, Australians.
Here's a...
Picture of a koala.
Like...
Oh yeah.
Also in EU too.
I don't know what they use for EU.
But like...
Uh...
They...
They did that for like...
Several things.
Like they did that for EU too.
So like any scene that got censored in Australia and EU were pretty bad.
They were...
I have to actually purchase the game from a European or Australian account.
So like I can't actually get the game in NA.
So...
I can't...
I can't get the game.
There.
Uh...
Um...
Anyway.
Uh...
Whoa.
Is that Doki Undertale?
Dr. Granberry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, back to Undertale.
But yes, I loved Undertale.
I still love Undertale.
I was obsessed with Sans and Papyrus.
Obviously, I was more of a Sans fangirl.
Yes, I was...
I was one of the Sans fangirls.
Like who was just...
Always fucking obsessed with Sans.
Like all my friends knew how much I love Sans.
That like one of my friends actually commissioned a very popular Sans fan artist from Japan.
To...
To draw me and Sans together.
And I...
And have Sans wear like my new...
Newscap hat.
And like I had that as my wallpaper on my phone.
For like two years.
I...
And I also have...
You know like...
Um...
In Japan and Korea.
They have these like...
Uh...
Resin dolls and stuff.
There is a really famous Korean doll maker.
That specifically makes Sans...
Uh...
Dolls.
And like I...
I bought their Sans doll.
And their Underfell Sans doll.
And I still have it today.
I was...
Fucking obsessed with Sans.
Like I...
My...
And I loved...
Underfell.
For those who don't know Underfell.
It is like an alternate...
It's a fan alternate universe.
Of Undertale.
Where the characters are evil.
So then I...
Because I was like...
Oh my god.
Evil Sans.
And it was a fan universe.
Called Underfell.
And...
I was like...
Oh my god.
That's so hot.
Evil Sans.
Oh my...
You know what's better than regular Sans?
Evil.
Edgy.
Sans.
Look.
I...
It was a dark time.
For me.
Like...
It was...
I told you.
I was obsessed.
With Undertale.
Guys.
Okay.
And then...
Um...
But like I don't care.
I don't...
I don't remember all the...
I don't remember any of the other alternate universes.
For Undertale.
I literally just remember Underfell and Undertale.
Those are the only two universes.
Oh!
And then there's like the one where Sans is like...
Reverse with Papyrus.
I don't remember.
It wasn't like...
But it was one where like Sans is Papyrus.
And Papyrus is Sans.
Like the personality.
Change.
There was that.
That was...
I don't remember what that one was called.
Um...
Was it Underswap?
Oh yeah!
It was Underswap!
And then there was Underswap Sans.
Um...
So...
So, I was obsessed with Underswap, Underfell, and Undertale Sans.
Just Sans.
Not too much about Papyrus.
I also commissioned a custom plushie of Sans and Papyrus from a plushie maker.
So, like, this was before Undertale had official plushie merch of Sans and Papyrus.
I literally paid, I think, like, $300 to have a custom Sans and Papyrus plushie.
Like, made because I was so obsessed.
I was in so deep.
You don't understand.
I was in so fucking deep.
I was obsessed.
Oh, and you want to know more?
I have a custom Sans helmet.
I have a helmet that was... that had LEDs of the eyes and I had to use as, like, a display thing.
Later when I'm back home, I'll show pictures of everything.
And to show you guys how fucked up I was in the head about Undertale.
Specifically Sans.
I...
I like how it gets where she's like, okay, oh my god, that's pretty... that's pretty obsessive.
I mean, but that's it, right?
And I was like, no, there's more.
You guys don't understand.
There's more.
I...
You don't understand.
There is more.
And then I just keep going and going and going.
I'm like, no, guys, there's still more.
I'm not done yet.
I also have... remember when I said that, um...
I only have one doujin and that was from Dynasty Warriors.
JK, I have two.
I've remembered.
It was something related to Sans.
I won't say who he was shipped with because I actually don't remember.
I don't... I don't remember.
I don't remember.
I just... Sans was like a bicycle.
Like, as long as he's in that ship, I'm happy.
Like...
I... I...
It's like anybody can be shipped with him.
I'm happy.
As long as he's there, I'm fine with it.
I'm...
Um...
A second doujin.
Anyway...
Um...
Anyway, so I was, like, crazy obsessed with Undertale, guys.
And my... I actually had, like, a lot of, like, their songs and, like, covers.
Um, and...
Look, no, it's even worse.
I did not care who he was with.
As long as...
Um...
As long as he was there, I was fine.
Also, all these Sans.doki has never...
Nope!
I actually did.
There is actual proof.
If you look through the archives from the before times, I defeated Sans three fucking times in three different games.
Like...
So...
So I did it.
I did do it.
I...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
But, like...
But, like I said, I had a crazy obsession.
Like, I...
I always have...
I always find one character that I'll be crazy obsessed with.
And then it would go really, really far.
No, it wasn't...
No, I never lied about not...
About being a Tumblr girl.
I told you guys.
I was on Tumblr.
Uh...
When Tumblr was a thing.
Like...
Robert, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I...
I didn't lie about that.
I was on Tumblr when it was...
When it was a thing.
Anyway, so that's my Undertale lore.
Uh...
I will show you guys pictures of everything when I'm back home.
I'll show you pictures of it.
Um...
When will I do it?
I'll do it on...
Next week.
I'll do it next week.
I'll show you...
Okay.
On part two of Deltarune.
I'll show you guys pictures of all my Sans obsession.
On part two.
So...
So you know how bad it got.
So you know how...
But I'm reformed now.
I'm reformed.
It's...
It's not that bad anymore, guys.
It's not that bad anyway, guys.
I'm...
I'm okay now.
It's true.
I...
Look, guys.
It's true.
I...
I got better.
I started playing Marvel...
I started playing competitive multiplayer shooters.
And I got better.
I...
I poured my obsession into long rank sessions.
Like...
Long rank grind sessions.
That's where it went to.
I don't know if that's an improvement or not.
Um...
It's an improvement to my wallet.
That's for sure.
Uh...
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks Doki for making me feel normal with my Doki merch.
It might make you stuff in my room.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You replaced one addiction with another.
Hey!
I got better.
Guys.
Okay.
Alright.
Let me boot up Deltarune now.
Let's see.
Okay.
Let me...
Wait.
Can I not...
Is this not full screenable?
How the fuck do I full screen this?
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's so tiny.
Why is it so tiny?
Uh...
Alright.
Deltarune.
It looks like...
Wait.
Where is it?
Why is it not showing on my fucking...
Oh...
Okay, guys.
Give me a sec.
Yes.
Continue on from chap...
Yeah.
Chapter one.
Yes.
What?
How do I...
Hello?
Oh, there we go.
Whoa!
Sorry.
I got scared.
Oh my god.
Please don't tell me.
It can only do...
I swear to god.
If this game is like...
Oh my god.
Please don't tell me this...
Okay.
Where is it?
Contact?
Why is it contact?
Hello?
Wait.
No.
I'm trying to get this game to show up.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Don't tell me it's window.
It can't be game captured.
I swear to god.
Can this game not be game captured?
Okay.
Contact.
Alright.
Bum bum.
It's...
Oh, I have to be OBS admin mode?
Okay.
Oh, that's awkward.
Let's see if I can do it here.
Okay, I can do it for this.
Okay.
That's fine.
That works.
Okay.
God, I hate doing window mode though.
Okay, guys.
Alright.
Alright, guys.
Apparently, I have to do admin mode.
I'm gonna disappear for five...
For ten seconds, guys.
Alright.
I guess I have to restart my OBS in admin mode.
Okay, F4.
Okay, I have to do...
Oh my god.
I can't re-chat if I have to do F4 full screen.
Okay, I'm gonna play on this tiny box.
I...
Okay.
Up your back, guys.
I need to stream on.
I need...
Okay.
Guys.
I...
Hello?
Oh, wait.
I stopped working too.
Oh my god.
Everything is a problem now.
Oh my...
Okay.
Guys.
I'll be right back again, guys.
I'll...
Guys.
Okay.
You can...
Yeah, but...
I can't see my screen.
I have to restart OBS again.
I'll be right back again, guys.
Okay.
I'm back again.
I'm...
Okay.
So we have a problem.
I started in admin mode.
But like...
Do you guys see the game?
Do you...
Do...
Don't...
Yeah.
That's what I thought.
Same here.
I...
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't either.
So we have a problem.
We might have a problem right now.
Guys, I saw... I put it in admin mode and everything, so I don't know why it's not showing up.
I... No, I did.
I did, though.
It's on contact.
I did near its specific window on contact.
And something is wrong.
Cause it's... It's on... It's on contact.
Okay, maybe... Okay, I'm gonna start a save file.
And maybe if I'm on a particular... Maybe if I start on a save file... And then maybe...
Uh... Are you... Do you guys see that?
Do you do not?
I don't know.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, I should... I'll start the game.
Restart the game.
Okay, I even started the game...
I started the game on admin mode.
Alright, see, this is why I love stream... Okay, I love streaming this for you guys.
Because we get tech support together.
We can tech support this together, guys.
Um... Alright, let me try this again.
What the fuck?
I thought... Is it because I'm on a laptop?
Is it...
Is it... Is it the laptop?
Is it the... Is it a laptop issue?
Uh... I even started on the... I even did it in admin mode, too.
But it won't capture for some reason.
It's so weird.
Wait... Okay, let me in... Yes.
Alright.
How old?
It's not even that old.
It has a 4080.
Alright.
Alright, come on.
Yeah, we hear it.
We can all hear it go...
Oh my god, I'm gonna go fucking crazy.
Alright.
I'm gonna start it on normal.
Um...
Yeah, it's on... Yeah, I'm on game capture.
I tried window capture, but it captures my OBS as well.
And like, that's weird.
I...
It...
It captured...
Like...
I know!
It's so weird!
That's so weird!
Alright, alright, so what the fuck I just got here.
Okay, so all I see, it says chapter one, and then I have three empty slots, and then three empty slots, and it says like, uh, empty, empty, empty, empty, copy, erase, character select, Japanese, end program.
I like how I like it, just Japanese.
Oh my god, I don't understand.
Okay, alright, am I like, no, we're just trying to figure this out.
Try Japanese, just put it in Japanese, it'll fix everything.
I think, guys, I won't be able to read what's going on in my game.
Um, no, I did, I read the tech support chats, they were saying to put it on, uh, game capture, and I did.
I have it on admin mode, I have it on admin mode, I put it on game capture, I did contact for game capture, and then, um, and then, uh, I put admin mode on Deltarune as well, and like, it still is not working.
What the fuck is going on?
Why is it always me?
Why, why do I always get the tech support?
I, no, and then I, I saw that admin mode didn't work for Deltarune, so I put it back on normal.
Um, yes, I tried to put it in F4 as well.
Uh, yeah, I tried a game on non-admin mode, and everything, so, and then screen capture just captures my OBS as well.
I, I, I tried screen capture when I was, went offline, and it only captures my, um, it captures my OBS as well, so I thought that was fucking weird.
I, so I was like, okay, clearly, clearly that didn't work.
Um, all right, all right, anyway, maybe it really is the game.
Maybe this is the game.
Have you tried, yeah, I captured, uh, I tried capturing, uh, other games before, and it worked okay, so, like, I don't know, maybe Deltarune just has, like, some thinking weird shit going.
Okay, let me see, okay, what do I have?
Oh, you know what I have downloaded?
We can, guys, all right, you guys want to know what I do have downloaded?
On my laptop.
Okay.
Guys, I do have something downloaded on my laptop that we could try out and see.
I have two games on my laptop, chat.
I just want you guys to know that I have two games on my laptop.
You guys, you guys want to guess what those two games are?
The two games on my laptop.
Don't worry, it's updating.
It's been, it's been a little bit.
Gee, I wonder what it is.
Because even though I am traveling, it doesn't...
No, the first game is Deltarune.
Why, you guys want to know what the second game is?
I have, the other game is Deltarune.
There's going to be a third game when I buy the nice day for fishing.
Give me a sec, I'm installing it right now.
Hmm, what could it be?
What could it be?
Alright, I'm booting it up.
Yes.
Alright.
You guys might be able to hear it before we see the...
It's a thinker, isn't it?
Ooh, what a riddle we have today.
What a nice riddle that we have.
What could it be?
Hmm.
Wait, where is it?
Why is the game not popping up?
Excuse me?
Oh, no.
Wait, we have some... Wait a minute.
Okay, we gotta fix this.
Oh, no.
Maybe it is my laptop.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
Please, I want to surprise my chat and be like, hee hee, this is what I have.
But wait a minute.
What the fuck is it?
Why isn't it launching?
Hello?
Oh, man.
Guys, I think there's other issues going on.
Oh, it's installing something.
Never mind, guys.
It's okay.
It's installing more things onto my laptop, apparently.
Um, because I installed this yesterday.
And then, like, um, apparently it wasn't finished installing.
Um, they're like, right now we're running, we're installing Microsoft DirectX.
And I was like, oh, okay.
Okay.
That's cool, I guess.
To overwork that.
Oh, my God.
Um, ah, yes.
The video game stream.
Look, okay.
Maybe, maybe I should have, maybe, uh, maybe I should have tested it out before I started to stream.
But, like, I didn't think Deltarune was gonna be a little fucking bitch.
I mean,
like, can you really blame me?
That it's being a little fucking bitch right now?
Can you really blame me?
I thought Deltarune would be one of the easiest games to stream.
But, fuck me, I guess.
I guess Toby Fox decided to add more things.
The fuck with me.
I, I, I thought, I thought it'd be an easy game.
I'd be like, oh, look at that.
Such a simple game for me to, for me to stream.
Because I'm traveling right now.
Whoa-wee.
Well, fuck you, I guess.
Fuck you, Doki.
Guess you're not gonna be able to stream that game.
But, whoa, I swear to God, if I am able to capture this game, that is definitely gonna be a surprise for everybody.
Right now.
I swear to fucking God.
I, if I can capture this game, and not, and not Deltarune, I swear to fucking God.
Oh, my God.
Alright, let's see.
Alright.
Did this game decide to be like, whoa, look at that.
Oh, my God!
Look at that!
Are you fucking kidding me?
There's no way I can capture Marvel Rivals.
Are you, are you fucking kidding me?
I can capture Marvel Rivals, but I can't capture Deltarune?
You gotta be fucking, I'm, I'm, I'm closing Marvel Rivals.
I'm, guys, I'm closing Marvel Rivals, it's gonna take 20 years to compile the shaders.
I, I cannot believe I can capture Marvel Rivals, but I can't capture Deltarune.
Like, it's, what, what game is this?
What, okay, I, I'm downloading chapter one on Itch.io.
I swear, I swear, guys, simple problems require simple solutions.
I'm downloading the game on Itch.io.
I, I, I, I, I, I, no way that I'm doing, yeah, chapter one and two are already free on Itch.io.
I'm gonna fucking download that.
Uh, I'm dead.
If it works, it works.
Alright, okay, download chapter one, uh, delta rune.
There we go, let me see.
Alright, does anyone have the original chapter one installer?
Alright, you can download it, I need, okay.
Alright, I'm getting, oh wait, where is it?
Where the fuck is it?
Wait, someone says, wait, does someone give, look for, and lower it to... Okay, if it works, it works, guys.
Alright, let's see.
Uh... No, I can't do screen capture, because screen capture shows my OBS for some, it like, cuts, like, only half the game shows up, only half the game shows up, and like, my OBS, uh, my OBS is like, uh, um, covers up half the game for some fucking reason.
Oh, I can't download them anymore?
No!
No way!
Wait, no, delta rune, okay, there we go, will be released on Steam.
There we go, download...
Oh, okay, there we go, it's on Itch.io, there we go, I'm downloading the Itch.io version.
I'm...
How are you gonna play chapter three and four?
I will watch my own stream, and replay it, so we get to the part.
We...
I will... I will tell... I will watch my own stream, replay it on the Steam version, and so we can re...
So we can have, like, an almost accurate version.
Like, we... No, that is how we're gonna do... That's so much work.
Well, fuck me for trying to fucking go... go somewhere to... to work on my concert.
Alright.
Fuck me for trying to, like, make a good concert, I guess.
That's my fault.
Alright.
Deltarune.
Yeah, I should never leave my... This is what happens when you leave your house, guys.
Never travel!
Never leave your home!
I swear to God, if this works.
I swear to fucking God, if this works.
Oh my God.
I would be, uh, so mad.
And happy at the same time.
Alright, here we go.
Let's try this again, guys.
Let's fucking... Alright.
Let's try this again.
I swear to God.
I... I swear... Oh my God.
I swear to fucking God.
You cannot do this to me.
I... Did it just boot up from...
Oh my God.
I swear.
If he, like... If this just came from the... Okay, I'm gonna uninstall this... Okay, wait.
I got an idea.
I got a fucking idea.
Okay.
Chapter 1 Windows.
Delta Rune version 3.
Wait a minute.
Okay, wait.
I'm gonna... What version is this Delta Rune?
What version?
Okay, this is version 1 14.
14?!
How many versions?
What?
Why is there so many versions?
Okay.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, Toby.
Okay.
Alright.
Run as administrator.
Okay.
Alright.
Version 3.
I have version 3 right now.
That's a lot of Delta Runes.
It is.
I was not ready for that many Delta Runes.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Toby.
I swear to God.
Please.
I... Download your Itch.io version.
I... Swear.
Are you there?
Okay.
Yes.
But, like, are... Can you please be on my screen, too?
Can you... Like, that's all I ask of you?
Can you also be on my screen?
Like... I'm gonna go crazy.
Like... Oh my God.
Wait.
Your start?
Okay.
Alright.
Please.
Stop talking.
Okay.
Uh...
It's not the laptop's fault.
I can play... I can stream Marvel Rivals on my laptop.
Why can I not stream this fucking... Do you know how big a file this game is?
Like, I don't understand.
Marvel Rivals was, like, 60 gigabytes.
You know how big this game was?
This game... This game... This game was, like... Okay.
Uh-uh.
What's the fucking property size of this?
This game was, like, 200... There's no way.
This game was 900 and... Oh my God.
How many... Okay.
I can't even tell.
I...
This game is 580 megabytes.
This is 580 megabytes.
There's no fucking way.
Okay.
Alright.
Do you guys see this game?
Do you guys see this?
I can't see chat.
Because I'm full screen.
No.
Okay.
It's not me.
It's... It's Toby.
Yeah.
We're on first name basis because that's how angry I am.
That's... That's... That's...
Okay.
Alright.
So...
That didn't work.
Okay.
I have an idea.
Guys.
Okay.
OBS won't...
Won't...
Capture...
Deltarune.
And that...
Does not work...
With...
Deltarune.
My idea is Googling.
Um...
At...
Alright.
Okay.
So apparently everyone was like...
And reopening OBS often fix...
Both don't work.
And closing and reopening also doesn't work.
Okay.
Okay, that's not very helpful.
Okay, apparently, this is an issue.
This is an issue.
Oh, okay, I have to disable hardware... where the fuck do I have hardware acceleration on?
Like, excuse me?
Close Discord?
Okay, like, what is this?
Why is there, like, a whole step-by-step guide on how...
Guys, look at this step-by-step guide on everything, on how...
Like, okay, look at this.
It was like, here are some ways to make sure you can capture a game...
obvious game capture even when ran as administrator.
Okay.
Alright, so it's not me.
It's just Deltarune.
Okay.
Try... ensure... okay, game capture and see if that works.
It came to try window... okay, we're not doing window capture.
That's... bit stupid for me to do.
That is... that would be an issue if I do window capture.
That is a little bit scary, especially when I'm on a laptop.
I do not... whatever is that.
This can't be my fault.
I swear to God.
It... I can... I... okay, guys.
I will prove to you that it is not my fault.
I will... I can stream any... okay, I'll show you why I know it's not my fault.
Because if I do... if I do... Super Mario Mon and I swear to God...
Like... my OPS would be like, oh, hey, I see you.
Look at that.
Do you see that?
Do you... do you see that?
Look at that!
Wait, you don't see it?
Okay, wait, do you see it now?
Do you... do you see it now?
Guys, do you see it now?
Wait, there's no ga- okay.
Wait, okay, I... I can't see it because Deltarune fucked up my screen, so I don't see anything.
Deltarune fucked up my screen, so like, I can't even... oh, oh, I can see it now.
Okay, it's okay.
I can see it now.
Okay, watch this.
Okay, wait for it.
Guys, wait for it.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Okay, give me a sec, guys.
I figured it.
Give me a sec, guys.
Give me a sec.
It's gonna work.
Okay, look, you see this?
It's like mega cropped out because I'm...
Look!
See?
This works!
Look at that!
It works!
This works!
So why the fuck does Deltarune not work?
Okay, I figured I know what to do.
Okay, I know what to do.
All right.
Okay, I think I know what to do.
I know what to do.
All right.
Why does it capture my OBS?
Deltarune!
Oh my god, if I wasn't on one monitor, it would be fine.
I am not...
I'm on one monitor!
I don't want you to capture my OBS!
I don't
want you to capture my OBS!
Okay.
Dave.
Guys, we gotta pivot.
We gotta...
All right.
Let me pay for this game real quick.
We gotta...
Let me buy this game real quick.
We're gonna pivot right now.
Oh, wait!
Okay, you're right.
All right.
You're right.
I'm installing another game.
I'm...
We're pivoting.
Guys.
I'll...
I'll fix it later.
I'm gonna...
Oh, wait.
Okay.
It's okay.
Everything is okay.
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
Maybe not.
Oh.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Everything is okay.
Again.
Everything...
Everything is okay.
Okay.
Just give me a sec.
We're 50% done.
Everything will be fine.
Let me...
You guys are gonna find out what we're pivoting very soon.
Apparently, we're not playing...
We're not playing Deltarune today.
It's fine.
My computer...
My laptop is like...
You know what?
Fuck you.
But that's okay.
That means we can start Deltarune next week!
Guys!
Yippee!
We can...
Alright.
There we go.
I finished installing it.
Yes.
Alright.
This is fine.
I have to install this game.
Now I have three games on my laptop.
If any...
If everything fails...
I have one good old reliable here!
I have...
Good old reliable bloons!
Bloons.
T.D.
I don't remember what it's called.
T.J.K.
J.K.
Wee Blooning.
All right.
Let's go.
I can't have this full screen, though.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
We have to do this.
All right.
That's fine.
Let's see.
All right.
We can do this again.
It's fine.
We just gotta get through the tutorial.
Here.
Put more dart monkeys.
I don't care.
Let's go.
There we go.
We're starting.
All right.
That's fine.
This is all calculated.
Return.
All right.
That's fine.
Everything is fine.
It's okay.
All right.
Let's see.
Auto start.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Please.
I'm already going through so much.
Don't do this to me.
I don't care.
Just... I don't care.
I'm going through so much right now.
Please don't...
changing the graphics settings to high performance.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
All right.
Goodbye, bloons.
I'll do one more.
I'll do one more fix and see if that works.
Okay.
NVIDIA.
All right.
No, do not.
Guys.
I can't access my NVIDIA settings.
All right.
NVIDIA.
Oh, wait.
I can.
NVIDIA control panel.
There you go.
Agree and continue.
Oh, hey.
I agree and continue for the first time.
All right.
Okay.
High perform... Where's my NVIDIA?
All right.
High performance.
Adjust... Where is that, anyway?
Video settings?
Where the fuck is high performance?
Okay.
Use my preferred...
Wait.
Where is that?
Oh, my God.
What is that?
Where the fuck is high performance?
I...
Okay.
Manage 3 settings.
Power settings.
Power.
Where the fuck is power?
Oh, my God.
Everything is all over the place.
Power management mode.
Okay.
Not that.
Is it the...
NVIDIA control panel?
Oh, it's been moved to a...
Win...
Wait.
No.
Don't apply it.
Okay.
NVIDIA...
Is it in the control panel?
Yes.
Okay.
No.
It's part of Windows?
Windows.
I swear to God.
We're just gonna create our character and we end the stream.
That's, like, literally it.
Okay.
Control panel.
Power settings.
Okay.
Power action settings?
Is that it?
Power mode?
No.
Okay.
Wait.
Where is it?
I'm on...
I'm on Windows settings?
And then...
And then what?
Try type...
Graphic settings.
Okay.
Graphic...
Oh.
Graphic settings.
Okay.
Now, where the fuck is...
Oh, advanced graphics settings.
Okay.
It has hardware accelerated GPU scheduling.
Where the fuck is the other thing?
Systems display...
Graphics.
Oh.
System...
Okay.
Add game.
Delta...
Okay.
Add...
Add a desktop app.
Where the fuck are you, Delta Root?
Where did...
Okay.
I'm gonna do this one.
Delta Root.
And then...
High performance.
Okay.
All right.
If this doesn't work...
If...
I swear to God.
If this doesn't work...
Remember who...
Who took away your Bloons gameplay.
Remember...
Who took that away from you.
Because that's their fault.
Because they gave us...
Oh!
Okay.
Let me...
We're back.
Back out.
Delta Root.
JK.
We figured it out.
Skip.
One hour.
Of text support.
There we go.
All right.
By the way.
This is the one...
What I download from Itch.io.
By the way.
This is the Itch.io download.
I'm not trying...
I'm not gonna try and figure out where the Steam version is.
I'm...
I'm gonna use the...
I'm using the Itch.io version.
I...
I cannot be bothered.
I will...
I will replay this.
This is...
This is the Itch.io version.
I cannot be bothered.
I don't want to test my luck.
Why is it green?
Because it's supposed to be green.
It's...
Just fix this.
Okay, fine.
I'll fix the Steam one.
Okay.
All right.
I'll fix...
I swear to God.
Remember who took this away from you if it doesn't work.
If I fuck it up.
Remember me.
Okay.
All right.
Let's see.
I can't believe it.
I'm uninstalling bloons.
All right.
Browse local files.
Here we go.
This should be it.
Okay.
All right.
Is that the right one?
Let window...
Okay.
There we go.
And then...
Okay.
There we go.
We did it, guys.
We figured it out.
Oh, my God.
I did it.
What do you know what I mean?
I...
Oh, my God.
I did it.
I'm a fucking genius.
All right.
There we go.
Oh, my God.
We did it.
We actually did it.
All right.
VOD watchers.
Skip one hour.
Are you...
there?
What if I just create my character and I just end stream?
I...
Can we...
Are we connected?
Wait.
Some guy.
Are you here?
We went through all of that.
I create my character.
I'm like, that was a great Delta Rune stream.
Now.
We may begin.
First, you must...